韩国剑头无书发
一起看看我发23万在小韩开的剪放盲和怎么样吧
我约的是汉南洞的这家
它是在地下一层的
店里面的城市是这种硬式风
然后省美非常好
干干净净的很初天
我原本想约的礼发
是没有当期了
雕低培小姐姐
帮我随机约了一位
剪发是7万7千韩元
我自己原本的头发就是
黑常知识
没有太久的城市
我主要的需求
就是把我休适一下我的山阳脚
还有太阳续和全顾
我给他餐烤的发型是这一张
你爸说我的剪断一点就跟餐烤途差不多了
那我们最终谈论下来就是决定整体剪断
让层次更明显一些
楼通完就去洗头了
我早就对韩国的暴力洗头有所二文
实际感受一下
你们看了真的很暴力
我就感觉我的头发就一直在为了拉车
剪之前会把头发先吹干
车的时候会给一个这样几个党饭
我觉得还蛮天心的
就不会把装容弄花
那现在就开简了
这个离发是真的是非常的感厉的
咖啡两包就确定了我整体的长度
他们简头发的手速真的非常之快
就感觉随便几下一个很完美的层次
就已经出来了
一直在努力的帮我休适山洋角
我的山洋角顺便就没
然后就是无止庆古的
打包 打包 还在打包
简完之后感觉我脑袋都清完一半
因为我平时是比较懒的打理的
所以我就直接让他帮我探了流汗
燙流海是九萬
杜里小姐姐就跟我上軟化劑了
那上軟化劑的同時
禮拜時依舊在不停的幫我
修減幫我打寶
因為我的頭髮真的是太厚太多了
那整體的行減的差不多了
就開始上腰水燙發了
這個時候我還在煤煤的
吃他們幾公的免費減餐
還不知道等會我將會面臨什麼
靠完沾下的那一模型
你真的是想做完
當然怎麼會這樣
好笑的
我看似在體面的味道
其實我的心已經兩位回合了
那還沒來得去反應
我就右邊拿去洗了一片頭
那洗完之後呢
就發現沒有那麼卷了
吹乾之後
它沒有卷棒把所有的頭髮都修過了一遍
我覺得這就是它們空氣感
髮絲的秘訣
但是我沒有什麼學會
好現在就已經在做最後的修件了
那根據整體的效果在調整一下
你爸是想解決一直誇我說
我的髮量很多髮質很好
法治很好
就是現在那個頭
把非常地好看
而且就是他的法治真的很好
平時的努力都沒有擺悲哦
那打力完之後呢
真的我覺得非常有喊味
這個流喊的湖度
正正好擋住了我的全股
那天我剛好感上
他們的周年慶還給我送了一些小禮品
這個裡面的失化打禮發磨
真的非常非常好用
香味很好玩
那大家覺得我花這七萬
只穿的大型什麼樣呢
I call it good to be a high girl
I call it good to be a low girl